[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tb 78 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un amoureux du
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
voile le skipper et binoy louis burton a
terminé son tour du monde en solitaire
et sans escale il termine finalement à
la 3e place sur ce vendée globe 2020
nous avons vécu de l'intérieur les
dernières heures de la course reportage
à suivre football conflent continue son
aventure en coupe de france les hommes
de carl priso se sont qualifiés pour le
tour suivant en éliminant vitry ce
dimanche
le résumé du match dans cette émission
le 10 sport la crise sanitaire impact de
nombreux clubs cette saison dans le
département à quoi ressembleront les
fins de saison pour le football mais
également aux le rugby interview à
suivre l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence donc cette émission par de
la voile et le vendée globe 2020
l'illinois à louis burton termine
finalement à la troisième place du
classement après 81 jours en mer nous
avons vécu de l'intérieur cette arrivée
sur ce vendée globe 2020 à regarder
bienvenue dans ce vendée globe 2020 nous
sommes aux sables d'olonne dans ce
reportage vous allez voir les dernières
24 heures du skipper et binoy à louis
burton
regardez
oh
[Musique]
donc
mais avant de voir les dernières heures
de will burton sur ce vendée globe 2020
je vous propose de regarder son aventure
il était parti en novembre dernier
depuis les sables d'olonne
burton a connu de nombreux
rebondissements dans ce vendée globe
2020 dès le premier jour le skipper est
sanctionné d'une pénalité de cinq heures
pour avoir franchi la ligne de départ
deux secondes trop tôt mais savait pas
encore que la victoire pourrait se jouer
dans un mouchoir de poche
on sort très bien passé évidemment mais
on va essayer de se rassurer en disant
le vainqueur à l'échelle d'un vendée
globe c'est pas grand chose
la capitale dans le décompte entre
j'avais à l'ordinateur et puis tu
j'entendais à la vhf
mais ce contretemps lui aura permis de
réparer son bateau et être parfaitement
apprêtée pour passer le cap de bonne
espérance
affaibli par de nombreuses avaries sur
sa grande voix le louis burton aura même
frôlé l'abandon nous sommes le 20
décembre le skipper qui n'a pas dormi
depuis deux jours décide de se réfugier
à l'abri des vents forts derrière l'île
macquarie au sud de l'australie
il monte sur son mât effectuer des
réparations en bravant sa peur du vide
c'est le bout du monde
si vous voyez bien le bateau ça ça fait
partie des trucs les plus les plus hard
que j'ai fait de ma vie d'un navigateur
système 3 pour en tête demain pour
remplacer look âge espère que vous
apprécierez aussi du plus bas on voit
donc maintenant on va descendre sans se
casser la figure
on va renvoyer la jv et on va lui même
pour entrer au ca s'ensuit une
magnifique remontée qui restera dans les
annales du vendée globe de la 11e à la
première position en franchissant
l'équateur pour remonter vers les sables
d'olonne dans la dernière ligne droite
il est au coude à coude pour la victoire
avec charlie dalin boris herrmann et
yannick bestaven tout se jouera dans les
dernières heures de la compétition
le skipper et binoy à louis burton
originaire de rambouillet arrivera entre
23h et 1h du matin ici aux sables
d'olonne son frère nelson qui a lui
aussi a grandi dans les yvelines à nous
explique les dalits moment de riverton
sur son bateau et surtout dans quel état
d'esprit les après autant de jours de
compétition je rappelle 80 jours de
compétition c'est la fin d'une aventure
incroyable 6
il ya 90 jours on nous avait dit que ça
allait se passer comme ça je pense qu'on
aurait signé tout de suite
d'une part parce que
il va terminer devant d'autre part parce
que a priori l'objectif sportif sera
rempli par rapport à ce qu'ils s'étaient
fixé qui était d'être dans le top 5
et puis surtout parce que ça court ça a
été tellement incroyable et parsemé
d'embûches avec le pit stop à macquarie
avec les ennuis qu'il a eue en dans la
descente de l'atlantique à refaire sa
cloison avec la remontée incroyable qui
fait dans la fin de l'indien dans le
pacifique jusqu'à être premier au
passage de l'équateur
il est 21 35 charlie dalin arrive
premier aux sables d'olonne louis burton
peut viser la seconde place au mieux ils
superbe performance selon l'yvelinois
éric bellion participants sur l'épreuve
en 2016 sa course est allé un peu folle
et il est allé dans tous les gros coups
de vent il a il est allé à fond à fond à
fond à fond tout le temps donc je pense
qu'il a fait vraiment une course
extraordinaire
il pensait vraiment être complètement
décroché par rapport au peloton de tête
et pas du tout il arrive dans les
premiers sera peut être le deuxième a
passé la ligne
donc je pense qu'il fait une course mais
remarquable remarquable à tous pas
louis burton achevée ce jeudi 28 janvier
un peu après minuit son vendée globe
arrivé en deuxième position sables
d'olonne il se classe finalement
troisième derrière yannick bestaven
arrivé après mais bénéficiaire de 10h15
de compensation et charlie dalin boris
herrmann son concurrent été contraint de
fortement ralentir après avoir heurté un
bateau de pêche quelques heures avant
son arrivée un tour du monde en
solitaire bouclé en 80 jours 10 heures
25 minutes et 12 secondes louis burton
achève ainsi son deuxième vendée globe
en trois participations en sept jours de
moins que lors de la précédente édition
en 2016 c'est une histoire sur une
dizaine d'années qui s'écrit avec avec
une équipe qui s'écrit avec un
partenaire avec des sponsors est arrivé
couper cette ligne en deuxième place
leur offrir ça c'est grande joie pour
moi une grande satisfaction et puis
personnellement une grande fierté parce
qu'il a fallu aller la chercher du début
à la fin
cette place le bateau un bureau vallée
de et bien à qui louis burton est lui
bien sur terre au rendez vous dans
quatre ans louis burton devrait
participer à nouveau à cet everest des
mers
rendez vous dans quatre ans et peut-être
avec une victoire au bout
encore un grand bravo à louis burton on
continue par de la coupe de france le
match devait se dérouler à fin octobre
s'est finalement tenue ce dimanche
dernier représentant du département le
club de conflans recevait vitry au 6e
tour de la compétition les deux équipes
de régionale une se sont livré un beau
combat et ce sont finalement les
yvelinois qui ont remporté à la victoire
le résumé du match à montage de rémy le
faire
ce dimanche 31 janvier conflent recevait
vitry à l'occasion du 6e tour de la
coupe de france dans une rencontre qui
se disputait à huis clos une atmosphère
particulière qui n'a pas bouleversé les
joueurs locaux
surmotivés les conflanais rate une
magnifique occasion début de match
quelques minutes plus tard conflent
prend les devants grâce à cette superbe
frappe en lucarne avant de réaliser le
break 2 à 0 avant la 36e minute
vitry tentera de réagir mais rate un
penalty juste avant la pause quand on
regarde de loin
elle est parfaite parce qu'on mène 2-0
mais y avait beaucoup de choses encore à
réguler il traversa la paire aplati
peut-être arrêter aussi
on peut le voir aussi de ce côté donc ce
qu'on avait la baraka avec nous
peut-être aussi mais on a tout fait pour
on a un surnom qu'on appelle celle et
dexter on tue direct est là aujourd'hui
on avait des attaquants exemple chez eux
et leurs montures en armes et à la
seconde période est moins riches ont
l'occasion les joueurs de conflans
défendent face aux offensives de vitry
les avesnois conserve finalement le
score victoire 2 à 0 direction le 7e
tour de la compétition très content
après cette belle victoire là c'était
dur
là c'était dur ça faisait longtemps
n'avaient pas le fait de match officiel
mais bon on a réussi à tenir les 90
minutes et voilà on a une belle
qualification et on va retravailler
cette semaine franchement aujourd'hui un
art au gré mot qui fait on savait qu'ils
s'en allaient gagner on allait rester
toute la semaine ensemble et qu'on
allait se revoir donc c'était d'été
c'était vraiment l'objectif numéro 1 de
se revoir et d'avoir une vie sociale
comme le coach le dit soir du coup elle
genre il te dire que c'est réussi et on
est content au prochain tour le club de
conflans recevra saint brice l'équipe du
val d'oise évolue également régionales
une
la rencontre se disputera ce dimanche 7
février toujours à huis clos
on vient de l'apprendre cette nouvelle
pourrait refroidir l'ambiance dans le
vestiaire de conflans le club biennois
aurait aligné un joueur suspendu pendant
la rencontre vitré a porté une
réclamation le dossier est en commission
et devrait être examiné à demain
conflent pourrait donc que être
disqualifié de la coupe de france
affaire à suivre ce match de coupe de
france était le seul autorisé dans le
département des yvelines ce week-end le
contexte sanitaire explique tous ces
reports situations à dramatique pour le
district qui a déjà perdu cette année à
2500 licenciant les coûts de jean-pierre
meurillon le président du district c'est
notre interio xpath
[Musique]
on allait au même point qu'il ya
maintenant deux mois c'est à dire qu'on
ne peut pas jouer au football
aujourd'hui il ya un match de coupe de
france c'est le seul qui a lieu dans le
département et simplement les tout
jeunes les tout petits peuvent
s'entraîner mais encore sans contact
sans s'en faire d'opposition son match
donc c'est quand même une situation très
complexe
[Musique]
c'est sûr que si le foot 2 reprend plat
très bientôt il sera très compliqué
d'aller jusqu'au bout des championnats
avec tout ce que cela peut comporter
derrière actuellement la ligue de
football amateur a prévu qu'on pouvait
faire seulement mais les hypothèses
seulement les matches aller puis ensuite
faire des play off et des play down mais
ça ça suppose qu'on reprenne les corps
prennent les championnats très
rapidement si un deuxième confinement
un nouveau confinement ce sera très
content encore plus compliqué je pense
que on prendra quasiment pas étant donné
le peu de le peu de rencontres qui ont
eu lieu en début de saison on peut
craindre qu effectivement ça sert mine
par une saison blanche ou et déjà on a
continué de faire un certain nombre de
formations on les fait on les fait pas
en présentiel mais en distance hier par
des visio et on tient nos clubs informés
de ce qui se dit et de ce qui se décide
au niveau de la fédération au niveau de
la ligue de football amateur niveau de
la ligue
et puis on continue de leur donner de
l'information sur le foot on espère tous
que in fine est ça finira par prendre
[Musique]
on sait que déjà actuellement dans la
paire du 2500 on est plus à 40000 on est
deux mille cinq cents en dessous là où
nous en sommes même si on reprend je
pense qu il nous en manque radôme il à
la fin de la saison
c'est dommage parce que ce sont surtout
des petits qui ne viennent pas donc des
primo des primes aux licenciés et les
primes aux licenciés d'aujourd'hui ce
sont nos joueurs de demain
la crise sanitaire qui touche également
le monde du rugby un sport ultra
populaire dans les yvelines avec 24
clubs dans le département depuis près de
trois mois comme pour le football et
matches ne peuvent pas à se dérouler et
la raison sera la saison sera très
difficile a terminé pour nous parler de
cette situation nous avons avec nous aux
lyonnais la galerie coprésident de
l'union ruby centre 78 bonsoir bonsoir
et pierre chevallier responsable
communication du club de versailles
bonsoir bonsoir mais quelle alors est ce
que vous arrivez quand même à garder le
moral malgré tout pierre peut-être oui
oui on garde le moral c'est à dire que
le rugby le rugby francilien et illinois
a montré ça je pense d'abord sa capacité
d'adaptation
lorsqu'il s'est agi après deux de
confinement de redémarrer le
alors certes un protocole qu'ovide droit
c'est-à-dire sans contact mais ça me
permet quand même notamment pour les
petites catégories d'écoles de rugby et
paul jeunes et aussi les seniors de se
réunir et de au moins de faire du
physique et un petit peu de ce qu'ils un
petit peu de technique
à défaut pouvant réellement jouer au
rugby c'est pareil pour vous lionel
messi est resté mobilisé en fait même
pas seulement pour les enfants et un
éducateur venue des petits ateliers y
lancer les petits défis dans toutes les
catégories
on a conservé effectivement le lien au
moins comme dit pierre effectivement né
au stade trois autres collègues j'ai
fait là nous interdit effectivement les
plaqueurs entend n'est pas plein on
n'est pas tenté de faire un petit chalet
mona on attendra de vieira
mais non on atteint un énorme engouement
chez les tout-petits notamment sean
connery vite ils sont très motivés ils
apprécié de ce malgré l'absence de
matches doit passer ce sens il n'y a pas
de lassitude peut-être chez allait
licencier forcément mai
je sais quoi je vais au rugby c'est un
sport dans notre adn et la bonne humeur
non ils sont rencontrés ce qui me manque
le plus c'est la convivialité et ses
petits moments de convivialité dont les
courses pour ta main même même si on n'a
pas besoin de s'attaquer donc vous râlez
on constate on constate la même chose la
même chose chez elle et chez les petits
avec notamment un tour de 1 taux
d'assiduité et présent ce qui est assez
intéressant et malgré malgré le fait que
ce soit sur des longues base du jeu au
pied une grande et prises des espaces
puisque justement il faut garder la
distanciation sociale et la
distanciation suffisante pour pouvoir
pratiquer un protocole convient de 3
mais ça reste convivial alors évidemment
à défaut de lassitude c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt l'impatience de redémarrer de
redémarrer et d'avoir des matches et de
reprendre le contact et le placage
lionel garrigues si j'ai bien vu un vous
n'avez pas joué depuis le 18 octobre
dernier c'était une défaite contre paris
40 à 10 vous n'avait disputé que trois
matches cette saison c'est bien ça
demeure un choix trois matchs sur au
moins deux matches alors le retard le
retard et il est deux ou trois matchs en
tout cas est ce que le retard est
difficile à combler et ça finit par
arriver de lehman source de leur retard
s'il devait ou mais si la saison devait
s'arranger
j'ai entendu parler de match je sais qu
il faut s organiser au long du match
aller ils seulement mais j'ai pas j'ai
pas cet optimisme la la le avec jacques
moreau on n'a pas cet opus
une nouvelle période de confinement et
de la possibilité de rattraper son
retard
vous y croyez peut-être au spectre d'une
saison blanche à pierre chevalier
malheureusement il est malheureusement
oui il se il se profile de plus en plus
c'est à dire que quand on fait des
calculs simplement d'agenda et qu'on
regarde les matchs qui resteraient à
jouer en poule puisque on sait déjà que
les phases finales ont été supprimés
pour cette saison donc déjà ça fait ça
fait une saison un peu particulière sans
ce côté tellement tellement idiomatiques
du rugby amateur des phases finales en
moins donc quand on regarde l'ensemble
des matches qu'il reste à jouer on se
dit que l'équation est à beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'inconnues peut-être
trop et que si on devait repartir en
mars comme c'est actuellement le cas
dans la compétition en main ça voudrait
dire
déjà qu'on soit susceptible et dans la
possibilité de faire de la règle et
isation aidé de l'entraînement avec
contacts avancés en février les
nouvelles que l'on as depuis récemment à
dire avec un rouge pour l'instant un
couvre feu étendu et renforcé voire un
prochain confinement nous laisse tous
ceux assez sceptique sur la possibilité
de reprendre saison et quand on sait
qu'elle va durer et ne peut durer que
jusqu'à juillet maximum entre eu lieu mi
mars et mi juillet ça ça ne fera pas le
compte
donc ce spectre de la saison blanche il
est bien présent on parlait peut-être
que deux matchs peut-être couperet avec
des play off des play down est ce que
vous y croyez vous à lionel garrigues
est ce que c'est peut-être une solution
face à ce spectre justement de la saison
blanche
[Musique]
partageant la même joie que les
footballeurs de talent dans l'ailé ces
noms ne manquent que ça mais je peux 7
puis comme pierre pierre chevalier alors
vous vous avez arrêté votre saison si je
peux dire pour l'instant le 25 octobre
c'était une défaite contre soissons
est-ce que tout simplement pouvoir
victoire contre 60 pardon est ce que est
ce que vous êtes pour l'instant premier
premiers du classement est ce que ça
peut aussi retarder votre projet on sait
que vous avez un projet à versailles de
monter dans les deux voire trois ans ça
peut être un coup de frein vraiment
c'est évident c'est évident que c'est
sarba sarba beaucoup de cartes
actuellement effectivement des premiers
de poule en fédérale 3 est toujours
puisque ça ne s'est pas jouée dernière
toujours champion ile de france honneur
pour l'équipe première à l'équipe
réserve s'est on est assez fiers de
pouvoir le noter jamais un titre n'aura
duré aussi longtemps pour une équipe de
rugby francilienne et régionales mais
hélas on
elle est obligée là de déjà de prévoir
la saison prochaine et d'anticiper un
certain nombre de points qui vont être à
prendre en considération
lionel leur rappeler tout à l'heure par
exemple sur le côté licenciés pour
l'instant on n'a de l'assiduité on est
les nos licenciés sont l'art sont
présents donc pas trop de pas trop
d'inquiétude mais mais c'est encore
fragile comme équilibre donc on va avoir
un certain nombre de choses nos
partenaires aussi ceux qui nous
soutiennent et qui sont tout le temps là
il ya ceux qui ya ceux qui nous
soutiennent coûte que coûte il ya ceux
qui sont dans la difficulté actuelle
économique et contextuelle donc il faut
faire il faut en gros faire le faire les
comptes et qu'on aura les annonces les
annonces à venir et qu'on sait comment
cette saison 2020-2021 va pouvoir se
terminer pour pouvoir rebâtir ses cartes
là est justement revoir nos objectifs
il y aura toujours les mêmes d'objectifs
de convivialité de clubs de club
familial de prendre du plaisir sur le
terrain
quant aux objectifs sportifs ils seront
un petit peu revue pas forcément à la
baisse mais au moment au moins 1000 ni
sur pose justement ce problème des faux
avec avec les partenaires est ce que ça
peut mettre en péril un club peut être
lionel garrigues chognard ses 78
de latence de nos partenaires et on sait
que effectivement le corollaire de cette
crise sanitaire c'est les crises
économiques et c'est avec beaucoup de
rouen les approches en ce moment mais en
même temps on ne sent pas et des
secteurs touchés que d'autres par contre
ce qu'on s'est dit c est que tout à
l'heure il y avait une question qui
connaissent quand fidéliser les joueurs
est quelque part où on a fait deux
matches la licence et à 220 euros
ça fait deux matches et 2 mois donc pose
la question de savoir si on va faire un
avoir quoi se reprocher aux joueurs en
avoir parce qu'elle est mais pour les
amener à aller chiner peas est hélas
très reconnaissant
dernière question qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter à tous les deux pierre
chevalier peut-être encore ans par jo
comme le retour sur le retour sur le
terrain après maintenant est ce qu'on se
le souhaite pour mars avril pour cette
saison là où est-ce qu'on se le souhaite
pour septembre
ça les prochains événements et prochain
événement le confirmant lionel garrigues
oui mais vous souhaitez vous sortir de
ce marasme c'est évident et le relance
douteuse le plus grand bien mais il ya
des choses plus de pages aubry est sûre
c'est sûr merci beaucoup à tous les deux
on vous souhaite de reprendre le rugby
le plus rapidement possible bon courage
à vous fois hameau des jeux olympiques
tony estanguet le président du comité
d'organisation des jo de 2024 sera ce
mercredi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sites hôtes
pour les jeux parisiens avec le cyclisme
sur piste
il participera à une rencontre avec des
élèves des classes de cm1 et cm2 du
territoire les étudiants découvriront
également tout au long de la semaine et
les autres sites comme le golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et la
colline d'elancourt qui accueillera les
épreuves de vtt le golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines qui
accueillera cette année l'open de france
du 6 au 9 mai le tour européen à la
fédération française de golf ont annoncé
cette nouvelle ce lundi après midi
l'événement avait été annulée l'année
dernière à cause du coc vide 19
l'heure aucun spectateur ne devrait être
présent pour l'événement mais la
situation sanitaire pourrait évoluer sur
le parcours les meilleurs français
devraient quant à eux participé à
l'événement on termine par de la course
à pied l'eco trail de paris le rendez
vous phare de la saison dans les
yvelines ne se disputera pas en mars
mais en juillet le 3 juillet plus
précisément les organisateurs ont décidé
de déplacer le rendez vous à cause de
l'épidémie de kobe 19 les organisateurs
ont évoqué l'incertitude autour de cet
événement pour justifier son report
cette 14e édition avait déjà été
reportés et annulés deux fois en 2020
cinq distances seront toujours au
programme 80 km 40,5 km 30 18 et 10 km
la course de 81 km s'élancera de l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
le 45 s'élancera depuis le château de
versailles les inscriptions ouvriront
dans les prochains jours c'est la fin de
cette émission merci l'avoir suivi à
bientôt sur tb 78
[Musique]
il